all right we've got a call here from
Britney in Missouri hey Britney how's it
going good how are you good how can I
help and so I have a fairly new Etsy
shop which has actually transitioned
from a different efficient shop that I
opened before and I had a situation in
the past when I very first open my shop
and I that's where my question stems
from so I'll just ask it to you do you
have any advice on what to do when
another small business owner publicly
and purposely tries to make your
business look that and I mean such as
like commenting and appropriately on
your social media posts sharing them etc
okay so this is a bit another competitor
it's not a customer of yours right it
would be like this particular business
sold some more items to mine and you're
sure they're not a customer so they're
not giving you negative feedback based
on an actual experience with you they're
just being hateful for no reason they're
being very okay well this is really
easier than Britney here's what I would
do and this is this is a little bit
taboo in the social media world but I
want to tell you this is something we
all stand behind as a company your
social media pages your accounts are
yours so you don't have to allow people
to be jerks on your page you don't have
to allow people to distract from what
you're trying to do now if someone has a
legitimate negative feedback they had a
bad experience with you they got their
product it was broken or damaged and
that's something absolutely you not only
want to allow leave it public you want
to super serve them make it right
rescind them a product that type of
thing absolutely but if this is a
competitor then you can block that
account if there's someone when we've
had this on all of our pages I've had
this on my pages where someone is just
there just stirring up trouble they're
just a troll there they're just being
hateful for no reason they have
absolutely no basis for it we block them
because here's that here's the reality
they are distracting from what we're
trying to do if there was some
legitimate basis where we need to take
care of this person we're going to do it
but if someone is just being hateful and
we know those people exist on social
media unfortunately then you have the
right not only the right but you have
the responsibility Britney to protect
your page to protect your business
and protect your customers because that
can be such a distraction that it takes
away from your other customers
legitimate paying customers their
experience it's a it's a distraction it
hinders your ability to serve them and
help them and so I know that there's
there can be this belief in the social
media world that you just let anything
go that anybody that has a you know an
opinion gets to say whatever they want
to on your page and we just don't
believe that it's your page and if
someone is going to be a jerk for no
reason then they get blocked and and
they unfortunately ask for that by how
they were behaving so it's kind of the
same principle in life and in business
you teach people how to treat you one
thing that's true in social media you
teach people how to treat you by what
you allow and what you permit and if
you're allowing people to be hateful
then they'll continue to do it and it
will take away from your business and
the customers that are trying to have a
positive experience with you but if you
don't allow it then the people that want
to be there that are behaving properly
will get to stay so that would be my
encouragement to you Brittany is just
block those people and if it's happening
on your Etsy pages within whatever
functionality have to delete those
comments again anything legitimate you
want to take care of those people you
want to serve those customers we want to
take care of bad experiences and we know
that all happens even if you're running
a good business bad things can happen
take care of those people but anyone
else you have the RET right not just the
right you have the responsibility to
protect your business and that includes
your social media pages